And in our business profile tonight
Mariko Yashida a two generation passing of the torch.
the Yashida family as Mariko Yashida
takes the helm from her grandfather
who built this tech giant
So have you decided?
What?
Mariko says we
can go wherever we want just say where
We?
I'm your bodyguard
So where do you want to go?
Let's just start with up
And then?
we'll see
What's this? Open it.
Interesting
Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new Marvel Wolverine deleted
scene video a new MCU Wolverine stuff
the director of the Logan movie was
recently doing a big watch along he
talked a lot about this yellow costume
deleted scene because he's the one that
actually filmed it he went on to talk
about the new MCU version of Wolverine
they also explained what was going on
with that Weapon X mr. sinister
post-credit scene if you wondered what
that was originally supposed to set up
big surprise it was actually for the
gambit movie so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything we'll do an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know
what you want them to do with the new
MCU Wolverines
yellow costume so starting with number 5
if you don't know what's going on the
director of the Logan movie James
Mangold was recently doing a rewatch for
the Logan movie and talking a lot about
the history of the Wolverine character
he's also the director that filmed the
Wolverine movie back in 2013 so out of
any director he spent more time with
Hugh Jackman working on the Wolverine
character developing him so he's also
the one that filmed this deleted scene
with the yellow costume naturally
everyone was asking him about Hugh
Jackman wearing it what's going to happen
with the new MCU version of Wolverine so
thankfully he had a lot to say about
that just explaining what was going on
with all this and what's going to be
happening in the future with Wolverine
inside the MCU
so in this deleted scene Wolverine and
Marko have just defeated her grandfather
silver samurai who is stolen Wolverines
healing factor his adamantium claws had
been severed during the fight somehow he
had gotten his hands on a ton of
adamantium so his entire silver samurai
suit had a bunch of adamantium weaponry
I remember there being all kinds of
questions about Wolverines bone claws
and him getting him out of an tiem back
after this movie came out so many years
ago but after this is all over he and
Yukio are headed back to North America
when she boards the plane with a special
parting gift
from Marco like she used her tech
conglomerate company that she'd just
take it over from her grandfather and
all that extra adamantium that they had
to create a special costume armor for
Wolverine is a way of thanking him by
giving him a special suit of samurai
armor to represent his order but is his
yellow comic book costume so he opens
the box and is delightfully curious
about it not really sure what to think
he doesn't
hate the idea of the costume he just
raises his eyebrow as ukyo smiles like
it's about to go down in the next
movie but number four you all remember
what happened after this is the next
movie was x-men Days of Future past they
had that post-credit scene that sort of
set up Trask with Professor X and
Magneto telling him about this big
threat that was coming with the
Sentinels in all of Wolverines scenes
during that movie after this point in
the timeline pretty much took place in
that post-apocalyptic future so there's
this giant time jump in the beginning of
Days of Future past so you never
actually get to see him where the yellow
comic book costume the way he explained
that yellow costume is that part of the
reason why you don't see Wolverine wear
it in this movie and why they deleted
this alternate ending scene is because
this version of Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
just aggressively hated promoting
himself in any kind of fanfare and three
you also probably remember it's a big
callback to the original x-men movie
where he makes a joke about them wearing
the matching black uniforms asking if
they actually step outside in broad
daylight where people can see them in
these costumes you actually go outside
what would you prefer yellow spandex
so it's not just the idea that Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine hates wearing
costumes is that Bryan Singer in the
producers at the time they were making
this first x-men movie back in 2000 were
deathly afraid of being comic-book II in
doing classic color uniforms in fact
Kevin Feige told the story about this
about how people fought him tooth and
nail he tried to tell them just do the
comic books because they'd have lots of
questions about how to figure out scene
how to get through character problems
when they were filming the movie Kevin
Feige himself was a producer this is a
picture of him on the set of that movie
but he was relatively low level working
at Fox he was a producer on the film but
he was only an associate producer so he
didn't really have any power so usually
he said that he would stand in rooms
during meetings with the producers and
every once in a while he would get a
chance to give his input but usually
people wouldn't listen to him at that
point it was until he became president
of Marvel Studios and he started calling
the shots that you really start to see
his creative shine through in the movies
since Bryan Singer Band comic books from
the set but Hugh Jackman wanted some
comic books to study up on the character
he just wanted some insight even though
they were going with a slightly
different version of The Wolverine
character Kevin Feige actually had to
sneak Wolverine and x-men comic books to
Hugh Jackman in his trailer on the set
of that movie how hilarious is that
Kevin Feige defying the orders of Bryan
Singer sneaking comic books so that they
can make the movie better but later on
when they were actually filming this
yellow costume scene James Mangold said
that Hugh Jackman never screened tested
in the costume itself they just made it
as a prop for the movie and used it for
this funny moment this alternate ending
but in the Logan movie when he takes
x-23 his comic books that tell the
stories of their x-men adventures he
appears in a version of the yellow
costume it's not the original yellow
costume because they had to change it
for some licensing weird issues with
Marvel Studios because at the time
Marvel didn't have control of the x-men
and there were some rules about what the
x-men movies could use for Marvel Comics
but when Wolverine picks up her comic
books and starts flipping through the
pages
he claims that they embellished the
truth and take everything to extreme so
like yes we all went on these adventures
but things didn't go down exactly this
way mostly omitting all the really bad
stuff that happened to them like the
comics were turning them into the
Saturday morning cartoon versions of the
x-men which is also meant to be a
reference to x-men the animated
from the 90s all those episodes are
actually on Disney Plus right now -
there's been talk of them doing some
sort of revival in the future but
because of the missing time period
between this movie and the
post-apocalyptic future in Days of
Future past I think it's safe to assume
that at some point the Logan Wolverine
character within the universe would have
actually tried on the yellow suit
because it's not yellow spandex is
actual real armor so - when James
Mangold says that the next version of
Wolverine will definitely be wearing the
yellow costume he's obviously talking
about the new MCU version of Wolverine
that Marvel will eventually cast they
haven't announced an actor yet because
it's still really early and because the
first major solo x-men reboot movie is
years away I don't think they're going to
actually lock someone down for at least
a couple years I've already done a bunch
of videos about the Weapon X Easter eggs
inside the MCU already and the Wolverine
deleted scenes that Kevin Feige tried to
work into the MCU there was an x-men
deleted scene in the original Iron Man
post-credit scene when Nick Fury is
telling Iron Man about the Avengers
Kevin Feige also said when they got to
Captain America the First Avenger movie
because they showed World War two during
that they wanted to include Wolverine in
a flashback scene when he's saving the
Howling Commandos so it would have been
a much younger version of James Howlett
Wolverine before he'd actually gotten
his adamantium claws so clearly there's
a grand history of Weapon X being set up
in all these movies and in present day
you have the weapons Plus program with
Thunderbolt Ross in the Incredible Hulk
movie in the upcoming Falcon in Winter
Soldier episodes which are going to deal
with the weapons Plus program and it
should go without saying but the MCU
version of Wolverines yellow costume
would also be a complete redesign to
this yellow costume is a good
representation for what it's going to
look like because it's the only real
Wolverine comic book costume in any
movie right now the number one that mr.
sinister post-credit scene with the
Weapon X program was actually supposed
to be for the channing tatum gambit
movie was supposed to set that up mr.
sinister was going to be the main villain
of that movie if you're not a big comic
book reader gambit and mr. sinister
actually go way back in the comics when
he was younger a gambit joined the
Thieves Guild and mr. sinister hired
them to steal the Weapon X diaries that
the scientists used while trying to turn
Logan into the Wolverine so gambit
breaks into the Weapon X facility just
as Wolverine
is in the process of escaping so gambit
Wolverine cross pass back then he steals
the Weapon X research Diaries but
decides they're too dangerous to give to
mr. sinister so he burns them so when
you're watching mr. sinister steam come
in and steal all this data genetic
samples for Wolverine that would have
been a core plot element during the
channing tatum gambit movie which kind
of died when disney bought the x-men and
Fantastic Four characters back so
currently the gambit movie does not
exist inside the MCU
they'll also do a new version of mr.
sinister and the MCU eventually -
originally he was actually going to show
up in the New Mutants post-credit scene
before they stole him for the gambit
movie the new mutants movie that will
hopefully be able to see this August but
hopefully that explains what's going on
with this yellow costume why they made
it for this movie why it wound up being
a deleted scene this alternate ending
it's still one of the coolest Marvel
deleted scenes ever so let me know in
the comments what do you want them to do
with Wolverines yellow costume inside
the MCU when they eventually do debut
their new version of Wolverine
congratulations Jose Martinez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my brand-new
Marvel Ghost Rider movie video and click
here for that brand new new mutants
trailer and x-men MCU breakdown thank
you so much for watching everyone stay
safe I'll see you guys tonight!